alexander sehr schönen guten morgen wir
wollen auch die afg schauen die haben's
geschafft ohne spitzenkandidat mit
streitereien wie bei den kesselflicker
und so weiter ein ergebnis einzufahren
dass sie zumindest noch im landtag sind
aber man wollte mehr oder
ja man wollte natürlich mehr 5,7 prozent
sind jetzt nicht all zu viel obwohl man
unter den kleinen der einzige partei ist
die es geschafft hat in der tat die afg
im saarland ist ein tollhaus da wurde
eine landesliste ausgestellt die dann
von unbekannter sozusagen von
geisterhand zurückgezogen wurde da gab
es keine spitzenkandidaten mehr im
saarland kein unfall da gibt es nur drei
wahlkreise das hat keine auswirkung auf
die stimmabgabe
die afg also über fünf prozent das ist
mit sicherheit auch protestwahl
potenzial das genügt offenbar immer noch
man hat nur ganz leichte verluste
gegenüber der wahl vor fünf jahren
erlitten über die wahl und auch das was
es an anderen baustellen in der afg gibt
hatte ich vor wenigen minuten
gelegenheit mit dem derzeitig einzig
amtierenden bundesvorsitzenden in der
afg bundessprecher genannt zu reden mit
tino
kfd war im saarland gestern abend unter
den kleinen relativ groß sie haben es
über die fünf prozent hürde geschafft im
gegensatz zu den anderen
trotz eines desso laden landesverbandes
offensichtlich macht das aber nichts aus
für die afg wähler sind stabil auf
niedrigem niveau mehr aber auch nicht
ja insgesamt möchte mir erst mal bei
unseren wählern natürlich bedanken die
uns die treue gehalten haben eine starke
stammwählerschaft auch im saarland und
am ende muss man konstatieren 18
parteien sind im saarland angetreten
davon haben es drei in den landtag
geschafft und darunter die afd
sicherlich hätten wir uns auch ein zwei
prozent mehr gewünscht ganz klar noch
dazu bei den wichtigen sozialen themen
die wir auch ein stück weit auch im
landtagswahlkampf gespielt hätten aber
wir sind eingezogen und jetzt hoffen wir
dass wir natürlich hier in den beiden
parteien cdu und auch spd paroli bieten
als korrektiv im landtag also für 5,7
prozent hat es gereicht die er lebt auch
vom protest gegen migration gegen
impfung auch jetzt aktuell gegen die
nato verteidigungspolitik reicht ihnen
das eben immer über die fünf prozent
hürde zu kommen und dann sich in der
opposition wohl zu fühlen das reicht uns
natürlich nicht wir wollen auch wenn den
westlichen bundesländern klar und
deutlich über die zehn prozent kommen
das haben wir zum beispiel auch im
saarland mit zehn prozent bei der
bundestagswahl geschafft ich denke wir
sind nicht nur eine protestpartei wir
haben viele soziale themen ich hab's
angesprochen auch viele arbeiter haben
uns gewählt das hat die erste auswertung
gezeigt da müssen wir ansetzen wir sind
die einzige freiheitspartei so sehen wir
das im saarländischen landtag wäre
stimmt wir in freiheit aber auch für
meinungsfreiheit ich denke das sind
wichtige themen die wir auch in zukunft
hier zu spielen werden ist zum beispiel
aktuelles thema ukraine krieg der
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine da gibt es
kakophonie aus ihrer partei einige die
da verhalten das kritisieren andere die
eigentlich auf putin seite stehen muss
da nicht klar sein dass das ein
völkerrechtswidriger angriffskrieg ist
zudem die afg auch klar stellung nehmen
muss die aktion hat klar stellung
bezogen wir haben ein positionspapier
mit sehr deutlicher mehr in der
bundestagsfraktion verabschiedete wo wir
ganz klar wie es als angriffskrieg auch
als völkerrechtswidrig deklariert haben
ganz klar gleichwohl sagen wir aber auch
deutschland darf sich in diesem krieg
nicht hineinziehen lassen das ist unsere
position damit wir nicht beteiligt da
dieses krieges sind es ist nicht
deutschland ist nicht in diesem krieg
wir wollen auch keine waffen liefern das
ist wichtig denn ich denke man kann so
ein konflikt nicht mit waffenlieferung
lösen wir müssen jetzt auf
diplomatischer ebene alles versuchen
diesen konflikt zu lösen und dh
diplomaten schickten statt waffen man
kann nicht ein feuer mit benzin löschen
aber mit putin verhandeln können sie
auch schlecht nachdem was er jetzt in
der ukraine angerichtet hat das war ist
völkermord der liegt ein land der
nachbarland in schutt und asche wissen
sie auch dann muss man weiter verhandeln
und muss auch mit dem präsidenten
russlands weiter verhandeln wenn man
anders lösen da so ein konflikt jedes
opfer als ein opfer zu viel und es wird
auch eine nachkriegsordnung nach diesem
schrecklichen krieg geben und am ende
leiden immer die leidet immer die
zivilbevölkerung das muss unter allen
umständen so schnell wie möglich beendet
werden russland muss sich zurückziehen
aus diesem konflikt muss die truppen
abziehen und danach muss man auch über
den nachkriegsordnung diskutiert gibt es
in der bundestagsfraktion da auch andere
positionen der frühere general leuten an
der bundeswehr auch in montag hat sagt
wir wird mit einer postheroischen
gesellschaft leben da sei man gar nicht
mehr bereit zur verteidigung des landes
von ihnen habe ich jetzt letzte woche im
bundestag wenn ich das wichtigen kopf
gehört habe im kopf habe gehört dass sie
selbst ihre kinder nicht zur bundeswehr
schicken würden weil das dieses land
würden sie so nicht verteidigen wollen
sie haben quasi das politische system
der bundesrepublik kritisiert was wofür
steht jetzt die afg eigentlich für die
landesverteidigung die es ja im
grundgesetz gibt als verpflichtung auch
oder gegen die landesverteidigung keller
werden aktuell nicht angegriffen die
bundesrepublik deutschland wird nicht
angegriffen das immer punkt eins und
haben sie jetzt meine rede sehr viel
reininterpretiert ich habe damit auf den
desolaten zustand der bundeswehr dem vor
allen dingen 16 jahre merkt hier
verantwortung trägt hingewiesen unter
welchen voraussetzungen eigentlich die
bundeswehr noch für die
landesverteidigung die ist wichtig und
hier muss es natürlich auch eine
materielle bessere ausstattung der
bundeswehr geben überhaupt noch imstande
ist und das sehen wir ja wie hier muss
es vor einigen im beschaffungswesen
endlich strukturen geben die auch bei
den soldaten ankommt und das ist den 16
jahren jetzt auch die letzten 20 jahre
mittlerweile alles nicht mehr der fall
gewesen und das muss natürlich jetzt die
bundesregierung auch gewährleisten dass
es wichtig oder reichen 100 milliarden
nicht nur aus sondern hier muss im
prinzip auch das geld richtig eingesetzt
und das ist bei den soldaten ankommt die
frage ob ich jetzt viel
reininterpretiert habe in ihre rede oder
ob das sich missverständlich angehört
hat thema migration hängt jetzt auch in
der ukraine krieg eng zusammen
möglicherweise kommen sogar mehr
flüchtlinge ins land als 2015 können
sich können sie mit der situation besser
umgehen weil es eben auch flüchtlinge
sind sind nicht aus muslimischen ländern
sondern eben ausländern sozusagen aus
dem abendländischen kulturkreis als
erstes gilt ist und das ist auch unsere
position dass wir die nachbarländer
polen ungarn denjenigen ländern
tschechien die aktuell sehr viele
flüchtlinge aufnehme unterstützen das
will ich auch wir natürlich finanziell
unterstützen dort die die humanitäre
situation dort entkräften und wenngleich
wir natürlich auch flüchtlinge aufnehmen
temporär auch das ist klar
werden wir diese unterstützung mit auch
in unserem land gewährleisten und das
ist auch unsere position
das heißt also die flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine sind aus sicht der afg hier
willkommen
wie solange natürlich kriegshandlungen
da sind auf alle fälle und danach werden
sie gestärkt auch wieder in das
heimatland zurückkehren weil das land
muss ja auch wieder aufgebaut werden
haben sie dass das eine realistische
perspektive ist bei den bildern aus der
ukraine werden die nicht vielleicht ein
großteil für immer bleiben müssen
verbleiben müssen wie gesagt jetzt reden
wir über die nachkriegsordnung schauen
wir in die glaskugel warten wir das
erstmal habe ich hoffe dass so viel wie
möglich ukraine wieder zurückkehren
können und dort auch friedlich leben
können so bei timo grub aller im
phoenix-interview bedanke mich sehr gern
ja fazit für das saarland für die
saarland war 3 afd abgeordnete kleinste
fraktion diese drei haben dann für fünf
jahre ihr auskommen als
landtagsabgeordnete und damit ganz
schnell zurück zu phoenix ins
fitnessstudio nach bonn